laura lippman has more than 20 books to
her credits another one of her works is
getting a hollywood treatment with the
upcoming apple series lady in the lake
starring natalie portman and lupita
nyong'o that's in addition to her latest
novel
dream girl set once again in lipman's
hometown
of baltimore i didn't hit the best
seller list until my 12th book
that was considered forever people were
saying you get three books and then
they'll drop you but they didn't they
stuck by me
laura lipman's career playing the long
game began as a print reporter
is there any one thing you really regret
in this campaign before moving from
writing articles about the city she was
raised in
to writing books about it her beloved
baltimore
i mean one thing about baltimore is it
needs love and if you're able to provide
that that feels good
when you look out here do you think of
all the places you drop bodies
i dropped most of my bodies in lincoln
park have i put any bodies in the water
besides the city itself lipman's best
known character is
private investigator tess monahan star
of 12 detective novels
by now though there is so much more
including her latest
dream girl a suspense novel about an
aging writer confined to his home after
an injury
things take a dark turn when he begins
receiving menacing phone calls from a
woman
claiming to be the subject of his last
novel the entire story plays out
in his penthouse suite in a
fictionalized version of one of the many
luxury properties popping up around
baltimore the idea for dream girl came
from where
it started with just the observation
of the isolation trope and horror
fiction
where misery misery obviously misery
misery of course is the famous stephen
king story adapted into a 1990 film
starring kathy bates and james kahn
about a writer trapped by his number one
fan
and forced to write a sequel with a
better ending remember how for all those
years nobody knew who misery's real
father was
or if they'd ever be reunited it's all
right here
lipman also says the country isolation
central to the 2018
horror film a quiet place influenced her
thinking
i've always wanted to write something
horror-tinged in a city
where you can see people and people
maybe can see you
and where you have your phone and the
electricity works
and you're still so isolated because i
felt that people were more isolated than
they knew
dream girl is it's it's crime it's
detective it's mystery
it's horror it's all those
yeah throw in literary fiction while
you're at it yeah sure
absolutely and it certainly takes some
um
i don't want to spoil anything but it
takes some pretty severe
harsh turns yes well if i write a book a
body's going to drop
you kill people i kill people that's
what i do for a living
lipman's last novel the critically
acclaimed
bestseller lady in the lake began with
another body
inspired by two real murderers in
baltimore in the 1960s it follows a
white reporter as she tries to solve the
murder of a young black woman during
that same era
you wrote about race a lot obviously in
lady in the lake
different than dream girl why why did
you feel like you needed to do that
i live in baltimore if i don't write
about race sometime
i'm not writing about baltimore but do
you think lady in the lake was so good
because you forced yourself to do
something different
yeah i've tried very hard never to write
the same book twice
and you know i'm over 20 books in
and it gets harder eleven years ago
lipman
and her husband fellow writer david
simon welcomed a daughter
she chronicled that in a rare personal
essay titled game of crohn's
republished in her 2020 collection my
life
as a villainous i was 51 when my
daughter was born why did you want to
document all that
i wanted to tell this story because at
the time i thought it was
unique like i don't know anyone
like me i don't know someone who's got
a kid in grade school in his writing
novels and just has sort of this
weird improbable life and what i found
out when i wrote the piece is that it
was far more universal than i ever knew
i felt like when i walked up to the
elementary school to drop my kid off
after that piece was published on the
internet
i mean i really felt like i was just
like you know walking into applause like
woman after woman
came up to me and said oh i so got it
along with
author wife and mom you can also add
mentor littman brings up and coming
writers to baltimore
and gives them a place to live and work
it's wonderful i've never talked about
it publicly and i probably shouldn't
because you cannot apply for the litman
fellowship
i must just reach down from the heavens
and with me and
yeah we're working on a short list of
people the office is under renovation
and i can't reach out to anyone until
i'm really sure when it's going to be
back
in working order well with full
apologies you might be getting some
additional applications
yeah well i opened my mouth so
it happened if you had forecast your
career
in 99 and looked at what you've done now
what would you think
i won't say it's beyond my wildest
dreams because i can dream pretty wildly
but it definitely hit the the upper 99
percentile of what i thought would be
possible if i got
very very very lucky she did get very
lucky and she's also very talented
libman fellowship applications here i
mean yeah watch out now i l
i hate saying i love it but the fact
that she had worked for so long
and then found the success and i know
we've told stories before like that
it just feels like somehow that it it
means something different to you at that
point and also the fact that some
authors do
tend to write the same book over and
over right she always forces herself as
we said to do something different
yeah i love that she's a journalist
proves that
there you go got some talent out there
beyond the talent we have that's right
yeah